are you a Kanye West fan I've look on
you I'm mad at him always we're always
kind of in a fight in my head but once I
hear you there I'm like are back Kanye
West returned to Twitter and at the same
time announced to be going to be writing
a philosophy book so I decided to go
around the office and see if people
could tell the difference between a real
Kanye West tweet that fake Kanye West
week and see if anybody would actually
buy a philosophy book uneasy well your
daddy was mildly he said that he's going
to be putting out a philosophy book you
hear that
oh what a make sense he says he's
writing the book through these tweets on
Twitter the tweets are the book so we're
gonna play a game where I'm gonna read
you quotes some of Kanye's some Bernards
and you need to say is it a real con a
tweet or a fake eye to you if you want
to see the true character of a person
watch how they treat someone who can't
do anything for them I'm gonna go away
yay only because on a song like you
always referencing like family members
of people rather than really
unless they want something some say yay
Oh like that but I would say I miss a
disease when we don't use me correct
that's a real carnival sir that's
correct yeah definitely Kanye where most
people fail in life because they major
in minor things that's good that sounds
like a DJ Khaled tweet Kanye Tony
Robbins real yeah we believe time is a
man-made concept actually time and money
you're bold man-made currency because
you can spend the bull I don't think
that's Kanye there's a little verb oh
yeah already pretty so probably Union
probably funny that is not a Kanye quote
that's a real time you're quoting this
game is stupid or not Kanye
damn you got it ha ha you were not born
on earth to please anyone you have to
live life to express yourself not to
impress someone I'm gonna go ahead and
say that would you buy a philosophy book
like I knew it
yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm assuming it's
gonna have dope artwork good
[Music]